ces mots n'ont fait que conforter
l'image d'arrogance et de déconnexion
dont nous souffrons hélas encore trop
souvent à l'étranger
certes le silence retentissant des
occidentaux face à l'intervention turque
est une honte mais celle ci n'est pas le
fait de l'otan ni de l'onudc du res qui
ne sont que l'émanation de gouvernements
nationaux
il est facile mais dangereux et le break
site nous l'a prouvé de désigner les
institutions supranationales comme bouc
émissaire de nos membres de courage
politique et ce n'est guère constructif
pour l'avenir de la sécurité mondiale je
voudrais également rappeler que l'otan à
70 ans il y avait le 29 états membres et
l'alliance la plus réussie de l'histoire
du monde
beaucoup de pays font d'énormes efforts
pour la rejoindre qu'elle a car elle a
su garantir la paix pendant ses 70 ans
sur le territoire des états membres
certes l'évolution de la situation
géopolitique avec la montée en puissance
de nouveaux acteurs et le des gants des
engagements des états unis doivent
pousser l'europe à repenser sa stratégie
sécurité et allait enfin vers cette
défense européenne structuré autonome
que nous appelons de nos voeux depuis
des années mais à l'heure où le break
site ag publie les dynamics européenne
de coopération en matière de sécurité
défense où rares sont les pays européens
ont accepté de consacrer 2% de leur pib
à leur défense et où par contre russie
chine turquie arabie saoudite ont
augmenté leur budget de défense de 30%
en moyenne ces dernières années votre
rigueur sont plus important de ne pas
érodé l'an fait de l'otan dont le
royaume uni et est encore question
monsieur le premier ministre
l'oeuf la france ne devrait-elle pas se
positionner en fer de lance de cette
réforme pour pouvoir avec empathie et
bienveillance construire cette robe
complète défense au lieu du tir de la
bleue de mettre au pilori le temps